مرتفعات الجولان عبارة عن شريط ضيق من
الأراضي الجبلية بين سوريا
وإسرائيل ، استولت عليه القوات الإسرائيلية
من سوريا في حرب الأيام الستة عام 1967
لتصبح أرضًا محتلة ، حاولت سوريا
استعادتها بعد ست سنوات لكنها
هُزمت في معركة دبابات ضخمة.
تم نشر قوة حفظ السلام التابعة للأمم المتحدة
في الجولان منذ عام 1974
لمراقبة وقف إطلاق النار.
في عهد الرئيس دونالد
ترامب ، اعترف بالمنطقة كجزء
من إسرائيل ، فإن الجولان له أهمية استراتيجية ،
يسمح لك موقعه المرتفع
برؤية جنوب سوريا
وشمال إسرائيل ومرتفعات الجولان على
حدود بحيرة طبريا كمصدر مهم
للمياه العذبة في المنطقة ، وكانت
هناك محاولات  التفاوض على
عودة مرتفعات الجولان إلى سوريا ، لكن
الاتفاق ثبت أنه بعيد المنال في السنوات الأخيرة
، وخاصة منذ اندلاع
الحرب الأهلية الدموية في سوريا ، تعهد رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو بأن تكون مرتفعات الجولان
جزءًا من إسرائيل إلى الأبد
والرسالة التي
أعطاها الرئيس ترامب  العالم هو أن أمريكا تقف إلى
جانب إسرائيل
أنت